enfin je ne saurais parler des droits et
devoirs d'une école qui rend heureux
sans parler du droit absolu pour chaque
élève de la République d'être en paix à
l'école oui le devoir du politique est
de garantir à chaque élève une scolarité
sereine je veux bien sûr parler du fléo
que représente le harcèlement scolaire
qui a déjà fait souffrir trop de nos
enfants et de leurs famillees parfois
jusqu'à
l'irréparable chaque élève a le droit à
la parole chaque élève a le droit à
l'écoute chaque élève a Leit droit
d'être protégé voilà pourquoi le
gouvernement et avec lui j'en suis sûr
une très large majorité des membres du
Parlement font de la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et le
cyberhcèlement une cause absolument
prioritaire pour notre école j'en ai
fait en tout cas ma grande cause pour
l'école et je n'accepterai pas qu'on
oppose cette priorité là aux autres que
j'ai évoqué précédemment peut pas
imaginer élever le niveau si on a des
centaines de milliers ou des millions
d'élèves qui sont malheureux à l'école
quand vous êtes harcelé le harcèlement
envahit totalement votre esprit il n'y a
plus de place pour autre chose il y a
plus de place pour les apprentissages
agir pour le bonheur des élèves à
l'école c'est aussi agir pour élever le
niveau parce qu'on leur permet d'étudier
et d'apprendre en
paix je l'ai dit nous devons
profondément nous remettre en question
sur ce sujet-l y compris dans les
pratiques qui ont pu exister dès cet été
j'ai publié un décret pour que désormais
ce soient les élèves harceleurs et non
les élèves harcelés qui soient contraint
de changer d'établissement dès cette
rentrée nous avons étendu le programme
phare pour que 100 % de nos écoles
collèges et lycé prennent pleinement
leur part à une démarche de prévention
de détection et de résolution de chaque
situation individuelle nous devons
remettre de l'écoute et de l'humain à
tous les étages des rectorats à nos
établissements dans chacune de nos
écoles dans chacun de nos collèges et
chacun de nos lycées de l'humain on
luttera pas contre le harcèlement avec
des plans ou avec des circulaires nous
réussirons et j'ai vu au Danemark mais
aussi dans certaines écoles de notre
pays de très belles réussites pour faire
reculer le harcèlement nous réussirons
si nous changeons profondément de
culture face s harcèlement et si nous
nous en donnons les moyens les décisions
que nous avons présenté avec la première
ministre il y a quelques jours visent à
traduire ce changement de culture ça
passe évidemment par la poursuite du
renforcement de la formation des
personnels par la sensibilisation des
élèves et des parents par le
renforcement des moyens humains dans les
académies et la mise en place d'équipe
d'intervention
dédié le 9 novembre prochain se tiendra
dans tous nos établissements la journée
non au harcèlement et pour la première
fois dans notre histoire un temps dédié
sera consacré dans chaque salle de
classe à la prévention et au recueil de
la parole par ailleurs internet et les
réseaux sociaux ne doivent plus demeurer
des zones de non droit où nos enfants
navigu en insécurité des formes de cours
d'école sans règles ni supervisation par
aucun adulte à cet égard je me réjouis
des amendements adoptés par vos
collègues députés dans le cadre du
projet de loi visant à sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique ces
amendements qui ont été adoptés il y a
quelques minutes à l'Assemblée nationale
permettront au juges d'interdire à
l'élève harceleur l'accès aux réseaux
sociaux pour une durée jusqu'à 6 mois
sans préjuger de l'issue de la navette
parlementaire j'ai la conviction que ces
mesures sont de nature à participer au
renforcement de la lutte contre le
cyberhcèlement mais